nobody's ever put me on a corner set me
down to hoe
i've never been forced to prostitute
i know that i can get money for my body
when i found out i can get money from my
body for the way i look
it was over
it was that was all she wrote
that was what age
did you figure that out
i was about 15.
i figured that out
that i can get money for sex
or for how i looked
or whatever
you left home i would age
i ran away from home at 16.
i was 16 years old when i ran away from
home is there something going on that
made you do that or you just
my mother was controlling
she she let me do things but then
she would stop me
like
it was okay long as she benefited off of
it
you know long as she was able to get
some money from whatever it was i was
doing
the second she didn't get what she
wanted
she just
everything all hell broke loose
so when you go to the streets at 15 16
years old 16 16 16
i was already
living with a guy
um you were yeah living with an older
man
i was already living with an older man
at 16.
um
this is a the guy who's taking care of
you or it was a trick at first it was a
trick yeah he was a trick at first and i
fell in love with him
you were you're 16 yeah how old was he
he was like already 43.
took care of me
i drove a mercedes you drove a mercedes
to high school yeah every day
he was taking care of you yeah
i was a kept woman yes you were
you treated you well
very well um took care of everything i
wanted and i needed
to where i didn't have to hoe i forgot
about hoeing
i didn't hold anymore oh you did you
stopped i stopped when i met him
and
[Music]
but i always knew that i can use my body
to get whatever i wanted i mean even
with him did you consider that
you were getting you're using your body
to get yeah to get whatever you wanted
right but i fell in love oh you did yeah
how long did that last
that relationship lasted
probably like five years
until i had my first daughter when i had
my daughter
and after i had her like we kind of grew
apart
he was the father
he was not the father he had a vasectomy
he couldn't even have children
so how did you get pregnant i got
pregnant by
the
first
black specimen that i thought
could give me some sperm
that would work
and i only [ __ ] them one time
and then i got pregnant with my daughter
and i never [ __ ] them again after that
he was a young guy he was like 16. i was
already 21.
is that is that the cause of the end of
that relationship
the end of what relationship with the uh
the guy you were living with
no it actually blossomed he took care of
my daughter he raised my daughters his
own he actually has my daughter right
now
to this day he has my daughter
with him
i told him i said
why would you
want to raise a child that's not your
own
but
he left her
as if she was his own
my daughter
she stays in malibu
like a few doors from the beach
how old is she now she's 13.
she stays with
with her with with my
boyfriend yeah
you suppose there's anything huh you
suppose there's anything
sexual going on with them
no yeah
no i don't
i don't even think he looks at her like
that
that's his daughter
my daughter
how often do you see her
i haven't seen her in a year
she thought i was dead
when i got shot in my stomach on
halloween eid
the day before halloween
um
[Music]
she she thought i was dead
the world thought i was dead
everybody thought i was dead
until
i surfaced
and i got out of the hospital the same
[ __ ] day i got shot
i got shot right here in my stomach yeah
sorry
with the 22.
there's a 22. yeah the bullet is still
inside my stomach
um
why are you in the streets still
why am i in the streets what keeps you
there
i think i like the streets
i've heard so many people tell me
they're addicted to it i'm addicted to
the streets they're beating me i cannot
beat them
no nobody comes out on top but people
are addicted to it
i love the streets
what is the attraction
i don't know
i think it's
there's no attraction to the street i
don't know what my attraction is to the
streets i just like to be outside
like to get shot in the stomach
huh you like to get shot in the stomach
you like to
do i like to get shot you like turn
tricks you like to do drugs there's
something about it
um
i like what i do
nobody's ever forced me to do it
i it's something i know how to do it's
easy for me to do
i'm good at it
and um
it's instant
i like everything that's instant i think
that's why i'm addicted to gambling
because it's instant and you're addicted
to gambling as well yes which what kind
of gamma you go to these little casitas
yes is that they call them yes
explain what a casita is
it's a private casino it's a
basically it's arcade games yeah it's
like little arcade games that are
set up in like an abandoned building
they're not legal no
nothing in there is legal
they're probably very illegal
yes
and to the point that they even like
move into a building that's released
without the owners no without the
landlord's knowledge
right right
well i don't i think they have the not
their their knowledge
they set them up everywhere all over the
place yeah they're all over there's some
down here on skid row but there's a lot
of them in south central
and i know where they are
what are the little games where you like
you hit something
i got shot i'm still tapping
i was still i caught the bus from the
hospital
and went to a casita and went to a
casino to gamble to gamble how much you
lose at night
probably five or six hundred dollars oh
so you're out there on the street making
money
getting shot
and then you gamble it away
yeah is that where the girls lose their
money all the girls are telling me they
make a thousand bucks or so a night but
no one can none of my viewers can figure
out where the money goes is that where
the money goes the money goes
uh
up in smoke like it's
basically you buy a wig
you buy a room
what the [ __ ] you buy something to eat
it's barely enough to you buy some drugs
you buy some no i never ride drugs drugs
but a lot of the girls probably will
they're giving to me yeah but a lot of
the girls will probably buy drugs yeah
they they will buy your own channel and
will they spend some of the money at the
casitas yeah
how much will you
spend there every time you go
um they're basically pimping me
but you told me you you spent five six
hundred that night
yeah
is that
typical um probably so it
it it can't give or take like sometimes
i can go in there with one dollar and
i'll win
five or six hundred dollars
i can go in there with no dollars i like
to go in there broke
see what i can come up with
make a dollar out of nothing
you can make a dollar out of 15 but can
you make a dollar nothing
who makes a dollar out of nothing but
typically you're losing right
yeah you're losing because it's your
mindset
you're
you want to win win-win-win-win
but you cannot win when
you have to know when it will
lead
that's what every gambling
shack or every
business like that you have to know and
leave no one knows when to leave
no because you start feeling like you're
winning or you're gonna win
or you can't win
let me get all my money back
tell me about your gold teeth
my gold teeth uh i got these about two
years ago let me see them
you got the whole
everything on top is gold yes
they are all gold um
basically i got these after i had a
physical altercation with a lover
not a pimp
because i've never had a pimp
it's always just been a boyfriend
who happens to have a girlfriend who
hoes
you're not a pimp he's just got a
girlfriend who hoes and brings him the
money
you reap the benefits of my
my
you know my
my wealth yeah
if of course you're going to share your
wealth with someone who wants to make
money and spend it alone
everybody wants to make money and share
it with someone
you're playing greedy if you just don't
want [ __ ] especially if you made a
thousand bucks or whatever a night
you wanna you wanna have fun with it
right yeah i wanna share it with someone
i don't wanna just have it for myself i
don't even want the money i don't want
money i want i want what money get get
gives me right
money is useless to me i give it away
but what money gives you is what a good
time
yeah
friends
yeah
some type of happiness and then you're
mad after that
but i gotta pee
okay go take a peek take off the mic
so you were telling me about your teeth
yeah so
what happened to your teeth
they got
kicked out
i got kicked in the mouth
and you had to replace them
immediately
this is how i do my businesses like i
talked to people like i didn't feel
right walking up to a trick's car asking
for a hundred bucks with no teeth in my
mouth he's like [ __ ] are you on crack
or what
like i i had never done crack you know
what i'm saying so
it hurt me to not have teeth in my mouth
and i was i'm so young like
that was my
like it devastated me the white gold
go be my mom had gold teeth
and it's a quick
fix it was a quick fix for me
quicker than something that looked like
real teeth
yes it was a quick fix
and
it worked for me
it kind of gave me some swag right
i got swag
in the streets that works
yeah
so i'm kind of trying to
cut back on selling the [ __ ]
like i don't want to sell so much [ __ ]
i'm gonna always
have [ __ ] for sale though
only because that's just what i do and
that's what i love to do is it just a
commodity
it's what i love to do it's it's
something you can trade for things you
want yeah it's easy to do and it's
it makes me money
it's my product it's like better than
a drug dealer
in this market
who
nobody is getting but we get a pop like
per
anything
[ __ ] is the highest
like it sells itself yeah easier than
drugs easier than yeah it sells itself
all you have to do is be pretty
you ain't have to be pretty the ugly
hoes make money too
ugly he'll make money real quick
you just got to be consistent
pretty much
now i don't even have to stand on the
corner i can just walk down western and
somebody sees me and
they've been looking for me for weeks
where have you been amber
pretty much
where have you been
you have regulars yes i have regulars i
have lots of regulars
people who love me
yes
tell me about love is love part of your
life
or is it just sex for money
i don't care if you're green yellow or
purple or blue
you got my money
you're gonna get your services i'm a
real [ __ ] like period i do you're
gonna you get what you pay for
you give me 50 bucks you're gonna get 50
bucks worth of [ __ ]
you know
you can't be
you
all trucks are different too
every trick is not the same
one trick cannot afford what the next
trick can afford
and
my product is like
you know how louie and gucci is
you don't shop there unless you can
afford it period
my business is recession proof
i do not feel no recession
pack of cigarettes go up
what the [ __ ]
one of the one of the skills i think
girls like you develop
is the ability to adapt to each trick
yes like throughout a night you'll get
one guy who's aggressive and
dominant and one guy who's quiet and shy
you're never gonna rape me you're never
gonna hurt me or nothing like that
i said a trick pulled out a piss on me
and i said why do you have this gun out
you did not have to do all that i will
give you this [ __ ] baby
like you don't have to hurt me or harm
me or anything like that like
come on i always find it odd that these
girls are telling that they're they're
getting raped with guys with guns and
violence and all that you can't you're
not going to write me you're out there
readily you're not going to rape me
you're very i'm going to give it to you
yeah you're willingly giving it no not
willing no but it's cost it's it's a
price on that yeah but do they just want
to be aggressive or they want to take
the without giving you money or what
if you
huh why do they why do they get
aggressive why do they use a gun when
you're already
allowed you know giving it away i'm not
giving it away i'm i'm selling i know
but they don't they can't afford it
that's why they have that that's that's
what i'm that's what i'm saying
because they don't want to buy it they
don't want to pay for it
basically that's why you have your gun
out but you do not have to hurt nobody
or harm anybody right at the end of the
day any hoe who puts up a fight is a
dumb [ __ ]
why would you put up a fight and get
yourself hurt or harmed or beat up or
anything like that
you're not going to beat me up or bash
my face in
[ __ ] that
i will give it to you baby take it
and move on to the next one
real talk and and that's just a lesson
learned you live and you learn
period
but i don't want to sell [ __ ] no i'm
always going to sell [ __ ] because
it's what i know how to do this is what
i love i love doing it i think i have a
sex addiction
at the end of the day because i be like
damn
i need to bust a nut like
let me find
you're not good enough
i get to get to go to running through
these tricks like at the end of the day
sometimes the money yeah i take your
money yeah i always want to be paid for
my safe for my services
but
i think i'm a predator too
but do you actually achieve climax
during some of your dates i always
i will climax
sometimes like
yeah what's it depend on
uh
if you know what you're doing you
you make me feel good i don't care what
you look like if you made me feel good
you made me feel good
period
right
are some guys just lacking the
technique to
get the job done
it can be
all right
i'm looking for a rock hard dick
like your dick your dick ain't hard
enough for me get the [ __ ] up out of
here
i may embarrass you
like at the end of the day because
it's not embarrassing me
you enjoy your work i enjoy my job
but um
that's because i think i have a sex
problem myself
so you have you have a drug problem you
have a gambling problem you have a sex
addiction you have a few addictions
right right shopping shopping is an
addiction
which one's the worst for you which one
causes the most problem
me
i'm a liability
this is all of it
right i tell a pimp like him
hey i would be
you don't want me as a whole
because i'm going to spend all of your
money too
and all of my money i'm a liability i
would not be
no smart pimp would want you really real
real talk you're pimping yourself
already i'm gonna pimp all his i'm gonna
take all his money too
pimps pay for [ __ ]
i've had a few pimps
they hold go out there and hold and they
spend a whole money on another hole
for real that's crazy right are the
streets just full of
like
addictions
too much of anything is not good for you
drug drug addictions sex addictions
gambling addictions shopping addictions
any too much of anything
is not good for you it's it can be a sin
it's all about balance it's all about
being balanced
[Music]
but
um what else can we touch on no that's
great you're you're so much more
fascinating this talk than the last one
last one you were more in a down mood
it was kind of depressing yes today
you're upbeat and fun yes
that probably wasn't a good day for me
yeah no but today was it you're you're
on it today i'm so glad you came by
thank you
so
where i mean are you learning anything
as you as you live this life
you've been in the streets for how long
a decade
um
i have not been in the streets for a
decade
i've been in the streets for about
four
maybe five years
like in the streets
yeah without my own place my own
apartment no i just mean like
working the streets
playing around in the
streets for about
since i could [ __ ] drive since you
were 16. since i was like 13 14.
and how old you know 33. so you've been
out there
a long time two decades almost
what have you learned
are you learning anything
yes i've learned things i learned
through streets ain't nothing to play
with
[Music]
thank you
cynthia
[Music]
i'll take care of you
okay
[Music]
all right just keep giving it
10 more minutes
10 more minutes so we're done i'll be
right there
all right
i understand why they're upset
i love you mark
i love you
you're fun
we're going to be good friends we're
friends for life
well we've known each other for a while
now
this is not the first time we've talked
this is this is maybe the second or
third it will be more to them
we're going to be good friends
you're fine
you know your friends are fun too you
brought me some interesting ladies
can you keep a heart dick
can i keep a what do your dick stay hard
without any viagra or anything like that
yeah of course
i don't do it
i don't do any of that stuff
but i'm not gonna have sex with you
either i didn't say you were i don't
have sex with any of these girls i
interviewed i never said you did
can you have sex with me
what
i'm gonna let you go down
okay you're fun today thank you
i'll be your reception
[Music]
i have friends like you all over the
place yeah all kinds of friends all that
you